وفقا لدائره الاحصاء الحكوميه الاوكرانيه
فقط بلغ التضخم في السوق الاستهلاكيا
لاوكرانيا حوالي 27% استمرت اسعار
المنتجات المستورده وتلك المصنوعه محليا
في اوكرانيا في الارتفاع بسبب اقتصاد
الحرب السلطات الاوكرانيه تعمل جاهده على
تنظيم ضبط مستوى التضخم في السوق
الاستهلاكيه خاصه بعد ارتفاع تكلفه
المنتجات المستورده والمصنعه في اوكرانيا
عددا من القرارات المهمه للحد من تصدير
المنتجات الى الداخل من ناحيه نتخذ عددا
من الاجراءات لتوسيع العرض ومن ناحيه اخرى
يواصل البنك الوطني التسعيره الثابت اما
ثالثا نحافظ على تكلفه اضافيه هامشيه
ثابته على المنتجات الغذائيه
على الرغم من ارتفاع التكلفه والتضخم
تواصل الاعمال التجاريه في اوكرانيا العمل
ومحاوله التمسك بالسوق المحلي الا ان
الامر يتطلب سياسات ون طبعا جديده من
الدوله وادارات الاعمال تتوافقوا مع حاله
الحرب بامعاني النظر في ارفف المحالي
التجاريه ومحلات البقاله فالملاحظ اختفاء
بعض السلع منها ومع ارتفاع الاسعار اتخذ
المواطن كذلك تدابير جديده لاداره اقتصاد
الاسره مما تسبب بشكل مباشر في انخفاض
نسبه لقوه الشرائيه في السوق الاوكرانيه
هو ارتفاع الاسعار ولاحظت اختفاء العروض
التروجينيه
اخر كبديل فقط نتمنى ان تنتهي الحرب بشكل
اسرع يتوقع
الاقتصاد العالمي هذا العام بنسبه واحد
تصل سبعه في المئه بسبب العواقب السلبيه
الناجمه عن الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه والخطر الرئيسي
للمجتمع دي خلال العامين المقبلين على
الرغم من ذلك ووفقا لوزيره الاقتصاد
الاخرانيه يوليوسيفر دينكو فان اقتصاده
اوكرانيا مازال صامدا ويتكيف بنجاح مع
ظروف الحرب وحتى مستوى التضخم في اوكرانيا
لا يزال تقريبا في ذات المستوى بالمقارنه
مع عدد من الدول الاوروبيه حذيفه عادل
العربيه كيف